[Música]
al borde de la ruta a 30 minutos en
automóvil del centro de Madrid se
encuentra el barrio de la Cañada real
esta zona irregular se divide en seis
sectores desde los más residenciales
hasta los más deprimidos Elena se mudó
aquí en los años 90 desde hace más de
dos años su barrio no tiene electricidad
una situación que afecta a más de 4.000
personas entre ellas 1800 menores
vamos la placa está fantásticas están
ahí encima del tejado pero el problema
es los inviernos el no tener luz es una
inquietud
impresionante el no dormir el tener
pesadillas el estar siempre Mirando a
ver qué pasa si la nevera se estropea si
la comida se estropea
Elena sobrevivió siete meses antes de
invertir sus ahorros en sus 18 placas
venga chiquitinas una solución muy
precaria bueno pues vamos a
ver Estos son unas linternas que tengo
para por la noche si a media noche Me
tuviera que levantar y estuviera a
oscuras pues tengo que utilizar la
linterna el 90% de las personas se
quieren ir de aquí
Pues mira esta es la casa Elena es una
de las habitantes más privilegiadas del
sector 6
caminando por él descubrimos estas
viviendas improvisadas rodeadas de
basura aquí sobrevivir es un trabajo
diario la zona es conocida por su
producción de cannabis un cultivo que
requiere mucha electricidad alimentada
por conexiones ilegales esta actividad
ha sobrecargado la red y provocado
interrupciones del suministro según las
autoridades
esta mujer desea contar su historia
anónimamente desde su vivienda poco
salubre para sobrevivir al frío invierno
tuvieron que calentar sus casas con una
estufa de leña y gas ayuda proporcionada
por las asociaciones y el estado
Menos mal que lo podemos contar
una encuesta realizada entre los
residentes reveló que cerca del 70%
sufría problemas de salud como
consecuencia del corte de electricidad
[Música]
en Madrid ante la emergencia sanitaria
que amenaza a los habitantes este
abogado representa a 200 residentes del
sector El supuesto motivo de las
plantaciones de marihuana no se tiene en
pie porque después de dos años y medio
las plantas ya se han muerto la causa de
fondo para no devolver la luz a 4000
personas es que estorban y que se las
quiere desalojar la inseguridad jurídica
de los habitantes está ligada a la
historia de la Cañada real una antigua
ruta de transumancia propiedad del
estado que se ha ido poblando
progresivamente desde los años 60 se
encuentra fuera de todo un marco
jurídico real tiene que ver con la
actitud que ha tenido el estado durante
todo este tiempo que ha dado a veces
signos de ir a legalizar o incluso
consentir de manera consciente la
ocupación y las viviendas que allí hay y
así ha habido
aproximadamente 25 años en los que se ha
pagado el impuesto al ayuntamiento de
Madrid
suelta a la cañada real nos encontramos
con Lidia es la representante de los
habitantes del sector 4 muy buena vecina
Qué tal todo al igual que sus vecinos
paga desde hace tiempo el impuesto sobre
bienes inmuebles una contribución que
terminó en 2011 tras una decisión
administrativa sentimos que ha jugado
con
lo que ha luchado a nuestros padres en
mi caso mis abuelos entendemos que todo
lo que están haciendo a día de hoy al
final se hace para que los vecinos de
Cañada no pertenezcamos no estemos aquí
a pocos kilómetros de aquí algunas casas
fueron demolidas
en concreto estamos viendo una dos
viviendas y Bueno un poco más para acá
tendríamos la otra se demuele un día
para otro nosotros nos enteramos porque
llega aquí la excavadora porque llegan
aquí los efectivos porque hay un
dispositivo policial cerrando que ya no
podemos hacer nada los vecinos de Cañada
[Música]
la situación de Cañada real divide al
parlamento de la región de Madrid
esta diputada representa su partido en
un grupo específico de trabajo para ella
la falta de Electricidad y las
demoliciones tienen relación
la realidad es que tanto el problema de
la luz como el problema de los derribos
ilegales es forma parte todo de la misma
estrategia Es que la gente se canse que
la gente no Luche que la gente se vaya y
para que así el gobierno tenga todo
solucionado
el año pasado el consejo de Europa pidió
a España que suministrara electricidad a
Cañada real